This
is the cow N.E.H. American English dialect recordings collection.
Tape number fifty two sigh.
B
D.
You know what she's an artist. She works at
home
she used to be a painter now she does print.
Yes yes he is a teacher
or professor at
Ryerson
I was born in
Toronto
and
yes we lived in Baghdad for year when I was
one of the other not
a restaurant or two others. Of your parents
they were born in Toronto. But yeah you're
pretty difficult.
So to ask questions just
distributers No not at all. Jill Carroll and to
keep her from care.
You just know my sister doesn't speak
French which she stopped after Grade eleven.
She's
just too tender to be twenty and you
know.
Skating.
Swimming.
Getting
in
competition
and swimming just things like instructor
and lifeguard tough no
competition just.
Canoeing masters.
If that is just one thing people badminton.
Skating my
favorite one and two
years and I enjoy skating to
music and exercising music and everything at the same time.
I haven't taken any ballet but I do like
dancing. So. Rarely.
You
know
I
want to figure skating
world. Special Events in general yes.
Not regularly No but I often do homework to radio when it's easy
homework.
Well it's my sister's in the room yes my mother's in the room something classical half I'm in
the room it's the variety of different
things but the rest.
Not regularly know.
Not
particularly
if perhaps French stations sometimes propriety and for French.
I
guess.
I was looking.
In the way.
Yes
porridge.
They was called porridge Cream of Wheat screens
we call
the living room. Front. Yes.
We call that sometimes I think we used to call it more.
Some stuff. We call the coach.
Sometimes you call we call it usually
coach just very
seldom do you
just see.
A little old fashioned If anything maybe.
I don't know. Coach. Sofa.
We don't usually call it that but it sounds more. To me than just a
field. Level.
Second floor. Below the main we call
the solar. For
recreation. Off and on it's got a printing process. Recreation
room and
stuff.
We don't know
just.
Whether
Well actually props are called basement quite a bit now because two years ago we
had it turned into a somewhat recreation room it used to be just sort of
hard cement and stuff only and at that time in the cellar so
I say cellar. But basement.
It's in there well now that perhaps even called our basement.
Now actually. School.
Changed. We had a cellar up until a couple of years
ago.
Serviette
if it's made of London or something I would call the napkin. But it's a
paper that's raging with.
No. Paper.
What's the last day.
Dinner. Well actually we would call it. Perhaps I know that already and that's one thing it's what we
call supper if it's just a little snap that you grab and run with and this we have got
to sit around the dinner tables and
dinner.
I
want
to for example if I'm inviting somebody over for supper and
it's just a little brother run type thing I always say potluck supper.
Whereas this is if we
have Christmas dinner or Thanksgiving dinners
been sent to them.
Jim.
But you would say gym class.
Running
shoes. You must be
a D.J. as if they are
Adidas sneakers. Nobody really says
much.
Startled
him. Snuck up.
True.
Right back.
Oh yes I can get the term for it.
In schools.
Though. Probably yes.
This is another to resolve but I can't remember it either doesn't
see their little difference.
Actually whether it's familiar but I don't think that was in the interim. I think there was another
one you
know
it's a company mail saying did
you
call
the which question.
Teacher's Pet I guess that's something else that you just played up to the teacher Brown
or studied a lot.
Q
R S. T. U. v W. X. Y. and
said. OK.
Thank you.
But along here in the line
there and
then
resume fast think about how cows wife lives.
Most of my tribe
would try to get
down around about north so then just a
field coach covered counter start
and greenhouse plow allow
allowed out double look lookout devout
but devote devout Scout guides brownies.
Mounties city council sword swallower clown. Wow So.
Cream cry out we poached squat.
By
trying to read it faster
than
to
just sort. Some
people to.
Do you think we are expecting.
Well there's an awful lot of American television of
course a lot of
candidates by America in that sense are getting more American than Americans that I
know tend to be liberal about a lot of things that Canadians are becoming the.
I don't really have that strong opinion on
whether
I don't mean liberal political slant. I mean serve wanting to be open minded about certain things.
Drugs whatever.
I
don't know if they were not but I think there's a tendency towards being more so-called open
minded and the Americans that I know
are
so I'm not sure some.
I
don't know if you're tough for me if I thought such and such is that or not I would probably be able to answer.
I like the idea stink Canadian but it's
probably deserve a natural reaction rather than
something terribly thought of.
The community of
British American We just find ourselves think. For not America.
I don't want to go through.
What
sort of
differences exist. People
just
more important who was elected to lead.
Somebody I know was asked Well it was somebody I know somebody I know somebody
else something about the prime minister and they answered something about the president. Referring to
Canada
and.
US that one week in New
York Long Island. Friend.
Yes I did.
Well the family I was staying with was very different and New York.
I guess is more of what Toronto is busy card busy
street shows
to produce. You know I like living in
Canada from what I
know. Just.
Of course American speaking of variety of different ways. I usually can't tell if somebody
comes
from I guess New York or not know depends of course on the area of New York that
some
part of the state for I can't tell the difference
between them and Canadians. Of course in the south. Everybody to
drag the big floor and the
whole tank in the Tennessee Ridge. I can't even imitate
it a different way to.
First.
Somebody
kept
saying
and
on the rocks. They couldn't figure out what they're saying is pressing that
rock. Just.
On
the Cap caught things
course
and catch myself thinking of course all the time and would refuse the cure for
expression
let's just
talk
with him.
When I was a. But I first came back to live on Cardinal place and I can't remember anything about that
because we moved away with
our three. That we lived on
Brownlow Eglinton
school and I remember. Brownlow that
big apartment that they used to be a small house
of. The our O.-W. in L. O.
W.. And.
I remember starting school. I loved that great Grade one
teacher kindergarten teacher. We moved away from there in mid grade
to over to build
farm road and that there between North front of
course but north of
Eglinton and we lived there until I was
in grade. We rented the area we rented
up until I was in grade ten. The
house they all had
cellars
or.
Yes.
When it's in the middle of grade nine and I started to smother grade
ten trying to grade not.
First children your
high
trying to a lot better. Because a lot of the kids in junior high are
snobby identify that with the
age more than the group but I'm not sure
who left
so
I was always a couple of years younger than the people above anyway so I suppose over the bit of a problem
but
for some yes girls on the street.
It wasn't as possible that those in junior high became a very good friend
immediately which
Fandy.
To Japanese I'm not sure he'd
want to do your family.
But yeah I think she's lived here all her life her parents were
Japanese but she's.
But
she's also in the one nine hundred twenty range younger than me.
Did
you
play. That
would begin to run. Yes a lot.
Yes.
Well I can remember better from
younger. Well skipping
scores different ballgame to
make up this game little boy across the street where we were high jumping
and a lot of the start off as two hundred fifty six different jump jump over a
certain height with all these different jumps and then to cut to the worst
bottom half your jumps and then take the next title to do the next ones and so
on until you can see how high you could do with your scissors or whatever your best.
Magister nice
to play a lot of different game to meet up
with magic things and
whatever.
The kind of.
Which
we were on the north end of North
Korea Parkway the part below i Clinton does a lot of
big houses. Compared to the house where we are
we're north of a Clinton does of Eglinton there's a lot of big houses the proper The
houses are similar to the houses
on go farm and
there are the housing but it seems to be about the same type of areas well.
You
just don't need to read it.
This is
a story about TO MY. And how they learn to live together the country most whose
name is Brownie was proud to live on a farm but one day a cow accidentally stepped on the mound
of hay where he
lived get out of here. Brown shouted but it was too late the cow had rested completely.
Now he didn't know what to do however he suddenly remembered that his cousin lived in the nice white house
in town just a few miles south of the farm he scouted around for a
suitcase which he finally found near the rusty old plow and headed down the
road when his cousin whose name was Howard saw him he was not pleased in
a roundabout way he tried to keep him out of his house.
You need to live outside he spotted. How could you ever live in a house. Please don't send
me away to country most a coward left me without a place to sleep and now I must
move into town. Please help me out. Howard saw the tears running down his
cheek and he felt sorry for
him looking down at the ground. He too began to pout. Gee he said
You make me feel like a lot
of course I would I will help you out you are welcome to sleep downstairs on
the coach. Come on in now and I'll get you a towel. You can have a nice hot shower
and wash the dust from your brow. I will even lend you a dressing gown and from that day forward.
The two mice live together very
happily actually which is.
Looking
as.
Well the guy was sent out of his house didn't really have a chance to show his good actions.
The Perhaps the other one but I don't know. I guess the other
one is more.
You
know it's fall back.
Somebody.
Be sure to tell you what
I think first of all the stuff is probably partly to check
out background
and maybe there's something in there as well as.
Obvious is Canadian raising stuff to try to ignore and read stuff like a sudden thinking
about it.
I think it's only just hearing this part of to figure
out what the cavalry views probably comparing. This area
to areas that come from other backgrounds.
No
for
a front room quite a bit actually we used to say it isn't
English because our grandparents are
English. So.
I think
just.
Putting. Trick or Treat.
And then.
Well not that one point.
I don't know if I did that or not.
Learning
difference
between. These two as far as raising
the two reasons.
You don't notice when I'm talking with an intern not
very
few
people.
I have seen.
And I think.
The
same
but
I don't think you know I don't think
so when I think about it and say that I
have a definite difference.
So what is.
This is. My choice
sure that'll be great. Now.
That
I'm
trying to find out when I get rid
of something
that is
coming
to.
That this really happened.
Well
if
they
have.
Question questions.
Like
deciding your
question would you rather talk about Americans look to Richard Roth to talk about the
separatists who never were both.
Question.
What
you're going to hear conversation to reading to think the
words
very
direct attention to.
This is
what the
question is not
because
they should be less. Different.
But
it's
OK
to.